[Music]
Simon we have we must address this
congratulations you are expecting your
first child really yes yes yes they just
came in over the wire I thought you
saved utterly no you even have to change
your lifestyle son because you're going
to have to because all these every time
I open a tabloid and I do every day it's
all I read you're in a different way key
car beautiful cars but not cars that
could accommodate a baby seat check this
out there you are and even oh there you
are fighting crime there you are
what is that what car is that that's
cool of you Cassie okay yeah I've got
that I know what that is yeah that's the
rolls-royce I could have a baby in a row
so you could definitely go in that yeah
no I don't see and then what's this I
think there's one last one there it is
that's the car that you keep in your
other car rolls so wait there's no baby
seat that's gonna go I think number one
will work which one was number I forget
there were so many cars we just saw okay
I'm gonna have loan you my Ford Taurus
no I don't I mean no that's a great
American car 92 okay you're gonna do it
you're gonna drive it it's gonna be a
new car what not asking you I'm telling
you all right let's talk you have you
mentioned dogs you mentioned that you
have you have dogs have a new new dog
two new dogs yeah and these dogs mean
there are photoshoots yeah these dogs
they did that first interview last
Sunday I've been a big third they did an
interview yeah how did the interview go
we they just barked but they will tell
you what had Kessler
talk to people actors
I get it so they cut it that they did a
photo shoot I liked it more of a
reaction when I send pictures of them on
Twitter than anything else and they're
called squiggly and diddly and they they
can even use squiggly and diddly yeah
that was a cartoon in the 1960s he was
an octopus who was a lifeguard could
squiddly diddly are you gonna be
choosing the name for the baby
it's Chilean Willard now today dear dogs
have talent do they have any testers
because I asked because I'm Britain Got
Talent Britain's Got Talent
they Britain Got Talent on that program
a dog can win that program and has won
has won yeah so so I'm just curious do
you know if your dogs have talent how
could it be honest with you Kona they
are absolutely useless oh I can't I
cannot train them I love that they have
been a tiny but they are really really
really badly behaved okay yeah so this
is the way you talk to you're
criticizing them the way you would
someone a contestant on on the show
yeah this is what you've you had a
houseplant you'd be like what is that
that's not growing we have a I'm just
curious we have a curious of your blick
this way by all animals because on on
your show they you had a donkey on that
painted I'm just curious how this there
it is yeah I'm on my favorite photos
from American television
how did this go by the way I had high
hopes that this donkey actually could
paint it because I thought we could make
a lot of money out of it and the truth
was all he did was they put a paintbrush
in its mouth and he just moved his head
up and down so he didn't actually paint
so we didn't put his approach zinc was
going to you thought the donkey was
going to be like holy yeah actually did
that so if you could put a man on the
moon why not have a donkey paint appears
like that you really thought the donkey
was gonna come out he really believed in
it and they didn't brought a Mexican
disappointed okay did he yell at the
Tommy he didn't yell at the dog
no his work that day I thought that was
an expert we don't have thumb keys I
said well how work though you've got too
many shows too many empires do many
donkeys